[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hagen John
where is that Furtick with Dear John and
Hank it's a comedy podcast where me Hank
green host of scishow and John Green the
author of The Fault in Our Stars and
several other books talk to you about
death and she questions give you two
beasts advice and bring you all the
week's news from parson AFC Wimbledon
I'm not proud of that one John no that
wasn't great I think it's weird that you
identify primarily as the host of
scishow well I was just picking
something what would you like on your
tombstone Hank what would you like it to
say that you did with your wife on your
tombstone giraffe sex videos that's not
even appropriate since all of our most
popular giraffe sex videos were made by
me I'm not one to brag I'm stating a
fact am I gonna have to host the podcast
alone because there's a spider in your
room or you can be able to do this get
on with it you know sometimes I think
you know there are a lot of legs in the
world but then I realized that most of
them are on that spider ain't green 1982
2146 most of the legs in the world are
on spiders I don't really know what to
do about this spider it doesn't seem to
okay it's gonna come to me well I mean
this is just a fantastic radio drama
it's exactly what listeners of dear Hank
and John tune in for every week Hank how
are you doing I'm good I'm good I had a
little bit of a spider scare I've got
I've got only good news in my life right
now
things are great well I have a short
poem for you today is it is it about do
you I mean is it only good news in your
life I feel like we didn't hear anything
about you my life is fine except I I
continued to have a broken rib which is
it just a tremendous bummer and but
talking about it doesn't help it but
also not talking about it doesn't cause
me not to think about it so why don't I
just read you a short poem of Correction
that was sent in by one of our
listeners Morgan all right let's do it
hey guys
pigeons may if rarely die in crevices
the deep chasms in earth and ice but I
think you might have meant crevices we
also got a got a correction formal Orin
who writes my father is the lead rocket
scientist of a science mission called
Juno that is at Jupiter at this very
moment right so Warren's dad wrote in
though it is a beautiful sentiment to
think that we will never know what lies
at the center of Jupiter we most likely
will within the next 20 months the Juno
spacecraft is currently orbiting Jupiter
and one of its core scientific goals is
to discover the contents and state of
Jupiter's interior to answer the
listeners question further once the
orbiter has completed its mission it
will descend into Jupiter to be
destroyed this is done so that the
nearby moons won't be contaminated but
the gas giant will destroy the
spacecraft it's also worth noting that
Juno has just sent back some close-up
photos of Jupiter that are stunning and
incredibly interesting including the
first ever photo of Jupiter's North Pole
so we'll post those to the patreon at
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John ah
they are beautiful pictures and I even
knew about Juno and had talked about
Juno as previously mentioned on my
apparently most important job of a host
of scishow and yes and I and I even knew
what Judah's mission was but I maintain
that we will know more about what is in
the interior of Jupiter but not all of
what is in the interior of Jupiter yeah
no I trust you over the guy who's
literally running the Juno project ok
let's get to some questions from our
listeners I want to start with what I
think is the most important question we
got this week it's from Pia who wrote
Dear John and Hank how do I tell my
family that I have secretly learned to
play the fiddle I recently saw an
amazing folk band and after their
performance I was inspired to learn to
play the fiddle I'm sorry I can barely
read
what what I don't know it's funny about
that part uh I had thought that that Pia
had already learned how to secretly play
the fiddle but it turns out that P is
planning for a future in which Pia has
secretly learned to play the fiddle
which is not a current current outcome
but no no Pia is putting together a long
con
Hank however I predict it will take a
while before I'd be comfortable enough
to play in front of anyone that's
probably a good point Pia I'm also not
totally convinced that you're gonna be
able to teach yourself the fiddle in
silence in secret somewhere but I wish
you luck in a few years should I gather
my family in the living room and appear
to them to their shock playing a jig or
should I just approach each member of my
family individually and surprised them
with their favorite tune
best wishes Pia this is the best idea
I've ever heard this has been better
idea than flying a spacecraft into the
center of Jupiter I hope that Pia has a
very large home or a or a garage in the
back where is this like PS pan hot time
in the garage
why does be a hangout in our soundproof
basement so much yeah I mean I think as
long as you're going to approach each I
think it's better if you approach each
member of the family individually and
play them their favorite tune ideally
arranged specifically for the fiddle you
but but in order to do that you have to
make sure that they're not going to
communicate to each other this has
already happened and the only way to
really make sure that that's gonna
happen is if you do this individually
with each of them at the exact same time
it's a great so I think what you have to
do is have multiples of yourself you've
also learned to play the fiddle yeah I
think when you learn to play the fiddle
all your clones also going to play the
fiddle although I'm not sure on the
science of that but my thought was I
totally agree with you that the first
person could potentially spoil it for
the last person so I'm imagining that
Pia has like four siblings two parents
and one grandparent who's living in a
nursing home so what you're gonna want
to do I think is first you're gonna want
to shock your grandmother you're going
to show up
you can have a duffel bag obviously you
can't have a violin case that'll give
you away you got a duffel bag you show
up your grandmother's sleeping and she
just she wakes up and she's like oh my
god Peola in the fiddle and then you you
cut your grandmother's phone line she
doesn't have a cell phone
thank God so you just cut the phone line
in the nursing home so she has no way to
get to the outside world you race no no
no - you have to cut that the phone line
to the whole nursing home so like the
exterior line right because she could
use a different phone I'm sorry Hank I
didn't think about great point so you
cut the phone line to the whole nursing
home then you race to your dad's
workplace he is an accountant yes nope
nope nope he is in the local Symphony
Orchestra where he plays the violin but
BIA had to see a band playing fiddle
before she was inspired to learn not
from her father but from some randos
exactly she shows up and her father of
course begins to weep because he's
always wanted piya to learn the violin
and now she's like a fiddle playing
maestro presumably I assume that not
only do you learn how to play the fiddle
but you're really really good and then
then you go to your mom's work she's in
a coma before before she goes to her
mom's work she has to burn the orchestra
hall home with her dad in it so he
doesn't tell anyone that seems like a
terrible plan he might die well I mean
he's not gonna tell anybody your this is
a real human being we're talking about
Hank this isn't fun in games we're not
having a goof this is for real
I apologize all right Jesus I mean Pia
has a real dad who is a real violinist
so then you go to your mom's work she's
the accountant you play her like what is
a great accountant song I don't has
never been a great fiddle song about an
accountant is the devil went down to
georgia about an accountant I can't
remember I don't think so you know I'm a
little bit worried that you've set this
this goof up and you've built in also
four siblings and oh yeah no it's gonna
be about 25 minutes long oh just to be
clear this is gonna be the rest of the
episode
pod I had a bunch of questions that
would add answer but I guess we'll get
to up next week yeah I mean seriously if
we get to them ever I I almost think
that we should start a spinoff podcast
entirely devoted to P as long khanh we
could call it P as long khanh which is a
pretty good name for a podcast I think
you should just write a short story no I
think so with the four siblings you're
gonna want to catch them all at the same
time because you're gonna want to see
all their faces as they react to both
your fiddle playing and to each other's
shock about your fiddle playing I mean
this is the best idea for a youtube
video I've ever heard of Pia you must do
this you must spend years mastering the
fiddle at the like you must let no one
know that you are mastering the fiddle
you must become the greatest fiddle
player since that Charlie's Daniel band
song about the devil going down to
Georgia and then you must do this and
film it for us yeah I think that the
hard part isn't gonna be cloning it's
gonna be finding something boring enough
to tell your family you're doing right
won't express any interest in it great
like Oh Pia has gotten so obsessed with
bingo
and she's always down at the bingo hall
nobody with the bingo hall because it's
it's bingo
but but maybe they maybe they will
accept that you've just gotten obsessed
with bingo and will also explain all the
money that you're spending on lessons
well I I understand was that Pia was
going to be a self-taught fiddle player
so that not even a teacher would know
about this long con I think you've got
to keep the circle as tight as possible
it should just be like Pia you me and
everybody who's listening to the podcast
all right well it is uh it is a
difficult thing to to pull off but I'm
looking forward to hearing in a few
years how it goes E in the YouTube video
if you live PA execute please let us
know so we can send a crew down to film
yeah for real I got another question
John is that okay with you yeah I guess
we can move on all right this one's from
Alison who asks dear Hank and John how
did the term real estate agent come
about is it because estate agents kept
having too
reassure people that they were indeed
real um you know the answer this
question John I do know the answer to
the question Hank but it's a little bit
like Donald Trump's plan to fight Isis I
feel like if I if I tell you the answer
then you know like everybody will know
it so it's best if I just keep it secret
it's BAE it's the best of it just inside
my head but I'm sure it's gonna I'm sure
I'm 100% right on this one let me know
if after I tell you this you think that
I am right you can confirm that I'm
correct about sure real the real in real
estate agent does not refer to the agent
who is definitely real it refers to the
estate and that it's a very old term I
think from like the 1600s and not like
this isn't the thing I knew I looked it
up and the real is a way of saying that
this is the stuff that is the real
estate rather than the personal estate
and so the real stuff is if you own land
anything that's connected to that land
is part of the real estate anything that
you can take away and it is yours is not
so like a tree would be included in the
real estate so it like the land and the
stuff and the rivers and all that stuff
it's the real part of the property and
then there's the personal part of the
property and which is like that's like
your fiddle would be in your personal
estate yes and your hammers and your
plow and yeah it's not really a way that
we use the word real anymore but it was
a way that we used it back then and we
continue to use that phrase and I just
love how words work John and how I don't
know why that is and I haven't gotten
over it I'm 36 years old and I still
love wooden people explain to me where
phrases come from words come from that
like you like dig digs back into history
and shows us that you know all of this
stuff is just a human invention and that
you know we are all tied together
through this long string of creation and
knowing and building ideas and and
things and I like that I don't think
I'll ever get over it well I think it's
cool too and I did know that I just
wasn't telling you um we have a similar
question Hank that allows us to talk
about a little bit of etymology which is
something that we both enjoy this
question comes from Gavin who writes
Dear John and Hank this is a very
important question that has bothered me
since I was a young child
why do almost all zippers have the
letters y k k on them you know I'm gonna
check my zipper oh it's a button fly
dang it dang it well I my zipper has YKK
on it YKK is an abbreviation that
originally stood for Yoshida Kohli go
geisha or I'm terrible at pronouncing
things I'll remind you that
mispronouncing things is my thing but
now it's just called YKK group and they
make your zippers in fact they make
almost all of your zippers I believe
they make like half a billion zippers a
year and the story of why they make the
zippers even though maybe Levi's makes
your jeans maybe Wrangler does maybe
seven for all mankind does but your
zipper is almost definitely a YKK zipper
is a fascinating story and you know what
it boils down to Hank what making
zippers good is hard like making zippers
that work is really challenging and YKK
kind of became the leader in the
industry because they have a really
great quality control in fact they smelt
their own like brass for the zippers you
know I I would love I don't want to read
a book about this because I don't have
that kind of time but I would love to
have read a book about this sure
and to know all of the the people that
were involved in making making that
thing happen you know this 82 year old
company that now has you know a huge
amount of the zipper market share in the
world
and why like you know obviously it's not
just a competition but they have done
many things to like to maintain that
position because I'm sure that people
could compete with them if they could on
price or on quality but like they've
just done a thing and held on to that
position for a long time and it seems
like there's a lot of people who have
never been appreciated for doing really
great stuff at YKK manufacturing group
yeah it's true the only way that they've
ever been shown appreciation is through
the hundreds of millions of dollars of
profits that they have each year I don't
know I don't know the early on maybe not
uh you know it's it's no they're a very
profitable company trust me I've looked
okay well that minute they're doing the
thing well they're doing the thing that
they can do and they're doing it well
I've got another question if if you want
to hear that John I'm ready
it's from Kayla who asks dear Hank and
John I can't buy into the awesome Sox
club it looks like it's already sold out
when will there be more awesome Sox
subscriptions did you know awesome Sox
would be so popular I'm yelling because
I'm excited not angry it would be
helpful for listeners to know that that
email arrived at us in all caps also
lots of exclamation points e yes we did
not know that it would be so popular the
awesome Sox club for people who don't
know is just a thing where we send you a
pair of weird socks every week a month
not every week it's a suck at the Month
Club it's not every we dance every month
and we did not know that it would be as
popular as it was and thus the first
month's subscriptions sold out quite
quickly
and we will get more of them in the
future and and they will be available
next month I think this is a fantastic
concept a sock of the Month Club because
my main issue with socks is that I need
about 12 pairs per year but I only think
to buy about 2 pairs per year so I'm
perpetually living with outdated socks
mm-hmm
yeah they're they're outdated because
they're no longer fashionable or because
or because my toes are sticking out of
the holes in the front yeah my toes man
they're always sticking out of the holes
in the front I don't know what my
problem is and you know weird things
really what we need Hank is YKK to
design socks yeah I smelt them out of
brass yeah that's it's like her could
flat but yes the sock of the Month Club
will be back soon in the meantime
dftba.com has lots and lots of things
for you to enjoy that aren't that yeah
just just squeeze it it in there also
our patreon zat patreon.com slash dear
Hank and John we're starting the
sponsorships a little bit early this
episode alright let's do another
question this one's from Alison did we
already do what from Alison this is the
second Alison I think it might have been
a different Alan okay
dear Hank and John do bugs ever have a
destination when they walk around last
week in my math class a beetle wandered
all over the room occasionally stopping
to switch directions or look around for
a bit
are they searching for a home or do they
have no idea where they're going thanks
Alison Alison I mean I don't I don't
want to cause an existential crisis or
anything but I'm pretty sure I could ask
the same question of you yeah
interestingly oh god I wrote I wrote a
haiku in college about this Oh God
it was about the human condition Oh God
I'm already I already feel like I'm
staring at the Sun and you haven't even
recited it I mean I can't remember it I
can only remember the last line which
was it wasn't it was some some other
form of Japanese poetry so it wasn't the
exact type haiku form that it was does
does a grasshopper
know where it will land when it jumps or
something like that
oh yeah well does it no I don't think so
no it's particularly grasshoppers which
do not jump to usually to get to a place
they jump to get away from a thing so
it's right there like whatever just go
and fly in random ways so that the bird
doesn't eat you right bugs don't have
the super advanced brains are aren't you
know they they are more complicated than
like a tree turning to look at the Sun
they do consider things and and like
have a number of different factors that
they are thinking that they're weighing
and they will use those factors to
decide what to do and where to do
the thing that they need to survive and
I don't and I don't think that we know
what all of those things are so we don't
really know what a bug is thinking about
like what it's smelling what it's
looking at we're you know like like all
of the sort of all of the inputs that
it's weighing in order to maximize its
chance for finding food or shelter or a
mate which are most of the things that
that bugs are looking for but we do know
don't we that like ants while they are
not particularly smart individually are
pretty smart
if you view them as like a collective
yeah yeah sure so so like if you're
talking about a bug that that is
responding to other cues from other bugs
then like that's one of the main things
that's gonna cue them into behaving
which is like like one ant found
something good here and then it trailed
a scent like a pheromone trail back from
that thing so that all the bugs are
behaving in very specific ways but there
are also bugs that do not behave
socially and it is very weird to just
think about like what is that bug
thinking there's that what's the beetle
doing where's it going and also
obviously you're not paying attention in
math class at all you just stare into
the bug maybe you should be paying
attention to you need you know
trigonometry over here cosines I mean
the more honestly the more you said
about what bugs are thinking and what
causes them to go in in this way or that
the more I think that if you just
replace bug with human you have a pretty
compelling argument about what humans do
and why sure yes somewhat I think that
we way more things but we we are in
general less complicated than we think
we are oh man
it's just it on an individual it makes
me distraught it also almost makes me
want to tell my favorite joke but I
think I've told it before on this
podcast oh you sure have god I love that
joke all right let's move on to a
different question this one comes from
Kathleen who writes Dear John and Hank
every time I'm at the dentist or
orthodontist I'm struck with the same
conundrum where do I look when the
dentist has his hands in my mouth do I
look into the powerful light above my
head into the dentists face at the
ceiling or some other place any dubious
at
is welcome sincerely Kathleen you know
what I thought was weird about this
question Hank is that I think the answer
to this question is super obvious oh wow
okay I also do but what's gonna be a
different answer than you are you sure
cuz let's just say our answer okay what
do you do while the dentist has his hand
in your mouth with your eyes let's
answer on three one two three
close your eyes you didn't participate
well I was taking the question in a
different way I wasn't thinking about
what what you would look at what you
should would do with your eyes so you
changed the question when you said what
you would do with your eyes and I was
thinking you would just lose focus and
stare into the darkness of your own
mortality right that's what you do when
you close your eyes like that's actually
you just literally defined what happens
when one closes one's eyes every single
time I when I'm at the dentist I think
that I sort of like just zone out and
stare into the middle distance and them
like what how did humans get here how
did we get at this point where like I
volunteer volunteer aliy exchange like
my only method of like of like defined
value for this level of discomfort I
yeah I would say that I get in the chair
I close my eyes extremely tight like the
way a child closes their eyes when you
say like oh just close your eyes and go
to sleep and they like screw their eyes
shut as much as they can I close my eyes
that level like very very tense for like
45 minutes to an hour until I am told
that it is time to leave the dentist's
office at which point I opened my eyes
of the world is bright there is hope and
a little bit of soreness and I leave the
dentist's office as quickly as possible
I do my best to not be that freaked out
but I do it like every time I'm at the
dentist like 80 85 or 90 times I have to
think to myself okay
stop with the clenching of every muscle
in your body
and I'm a pretty relaxed person but it's
just like no matter what I'm like and my
shoulders go up and like my abs clench
and I'm just like and then I'm like okay
stop doing that why are you doing that
what do you think is gonna make how is
that making things better and then
immediately after I stop thinking
everything conscious again ya know I
mean I don't even think it's worth
drawing you just close your eyes at the
dentist's office like don't don't look
at anything
it's it I yeah I I'm actually Hank I'm
getting super stressed out answering
this question I want to move on to a
different question I haven't been by the
way I haven't been to the dentist in
like six or seven weeks which is I think
the longest I've gone without being at
the dentist in years and I'm so grateful
I'm also so mad at like 20-year old me
for his terrible oral hygiene let's just
move on to another question this one
comes from Tim who writes dear green
brothers well that's a nice way to solve
the dear Hank and John problem I live in
Germany and the government released a
new emergency plan this plan recommends
that everyone should keep emergency
rations of food and water for at least
10 days personally I don't think there's
a need to keep emergency rations and
that this recommendation more so than
anything else encourages fear of terror
attacks what do you think about this do
you keep emergency rations at home best
wishes and gutentag I mean I am
surprised like uh when I hear emergency
rations I don't immediately think only
terror attacks certainly that's one of
the things what I mean but I don't know
what else is gonna happen that's gonna
result in ten days of food making a lick
of difference um the like a giant solar
flare that knocks out the entire
electric grid of year right I just don't
think that that's gonna get solved in
nine days I think that having enough
food and water for ten days is gonna
dramatically increase Germany's chance
of of having that end without like a
massive social upheaval can I ask you a
follow-up question how likely is a solar
flare that knocks out power to all of
Europe or more importantly all of the
United States having it happen anywhere
on earth you know in any given year
probably a
one in 500 to one in 1,000 chance so way
too likely yeah that is too likely it's
terrifying it is the reason that you
should hire right I'm gonna get myself
some emergency rations immediately
because right now all I have is like 196
Snickers bars I mean I think that could
hold me over yeah probably I think I
think your Snickers bars probably you
just hold up stop eating them leave them
down the basement I I have water I have
water stored up because like I can go a
long time without food John but you
cannot go a long time without water so I
have no water stored up I have nothing
stored up I should definitely go get
some water I mean is this becoming a
survivalist podcast because I always
thought my answer to this question was
gonna be like I agree with you it's all
fear-mongering I'm 38 years old I've
never needed one day's rations but alone
ten days and yet now I'm like I need to
go buy 50 gallons of water immediately I
mean I don't you know it's it's it is an
outside insurance plan and the thing to
know about it is that like what the
government does Germany is asking for is
probably a two hundred dollar investment
that you make once every ten years hmm
and so it is it is a pretty inexpensive
thing to do and really what what you
know like their goal is to increase the
number of people that have this so that
when they're providing emergency
services during you know a giant solar
flare or in the wake of like some kind
of I mean I honestly I don't think that
a terrorist attack like is going to
create a need for that unless it's like
you know somebody found an atomic bomb
or something it was just in the basement
gathering dust that you you know like
they're just trying to make emergency
services easier if more people have the
ability to take care of themselves for a
little while that makes life a lot
easier for that the services that the
people who are trying to provide those
services okay alright so there you go
ladies and gentlemen get yourself some
water and some emergency Snickers bars I
recommend no fewer than 378 at any
all right speaking of the Mars company
this question is from Angie who asks
dear Hank and John I work in a movie
theater that sells like most theaters
overpriced candy all theaters thank you
very much Angie and one of these candies
just so happens to be punitive and M's I
noticed that many of the guests got I
love peanut M&Ms I love them so much
that ordered this type of candy called
them M&Ms peanuts or M&M peanuts since I
know that Hank is an expert in all
things peanut M&Ms I wonder if I was
wondering if M&M peanuts is really an
acceptable way of describing these
candies have you ever heard of this John
I have never heard of it I think it's a
totally unacceptable way of describing
peanut M&Ms but I just want to pause for
a second and note that you are only
asking this question Hank because you
know that the Mars company sent me 378
Snickers bars and you are desperate to
try to get yourself some free M&Ms
I do love peanut M&Ms so but I also
before the podcast began asked on
Twitter before we started recording
what do you call Eminem's that have
peanuts inside and 5 percent of people
said Eminem's peanut and so weird yeah
so it's a thing and then I asked ok if
you're an Eminem's peanut person explain
yourself
did you just click incorrectly or is
that really a thing and and one person
did indeed respond let me find it real
quick and said I call it Eminem's peanut
I guess it's a thing stop making me
second-guess myself so it is it which by
the way fair enough like I think there
are enough things going on in the
average human life that being called to
account over how you say peanut M&Ms
probably isn't helpful but so I looked
at the packaging of peanut M&Ms and it
says Eminem's really big and then in the
upper left hand corner and small type it
says peanut and so you could read that
you know some left to left to right top
to bottom peanut M&Ms or you can read it
from like largest to smallest thing and
say M&Ms peanut so it makes sense that
there's that there's a thing here people
are telling me
like oh it doesn't make sense one way
and I'm like okay shush it whether it
makes sense like we know what you're
talking about it's not grammatically
inconsistent and maybe there is like an
element of you know like where you put
the adjective and where you put the noun
but like my Honda Civic isn't a civic
honda that's the brand name followed by
the modifier so like it's a thing that
happens we do that we do brand name
followed by modifier sometimes alright
so in short you are in the end saying
that either peanut M&Ms or M&M peanuts
should be seen as acceptable yes except
that the Mars company does indeed agree
that they are peanut M&Ms okay well I
think the Mars company should have the
final say on this since they are our
most important corporate sponsor moving
on here's a question from Barbara who
writes Dear John and Hank I was
intrigued to hear John pronounce another
like pronunciation question I was
intrigued to hear John pronounce orange
with two syllables but Hank pronounced
it with only one syllable in my house
the parents version is two syllables but
the kids version is only one syllable I
attribute this to the fact that I grew
up in Ohio while my parents grew up on
the East Coast but the two of you lived
together when you were small children
correct so why the difference
well our mother is from the South John
spent a lot of time in the south growing
up and I did not and I our father is
more of a Hoosier more of a Yankee and
that I currently live in the great
American middle west and I'm and I'm
most of my speech now is is Middle West
or not not southern so I'm surprised to
know that we pronounce Orange
differently how do you pronounce it
Orange how do I pronounce it orange
orange orange orange orange orange okay
I'm just gonna try it I'm just gonna try
to say it in a sentence I literally
can't think of something that's Orange
ah I do say it in two syllables you're
right
orange yeah okay so I need to start
saying it in one syllable so that the
big lie will not be revealed tank which
of course is that we are not actually
brothers we are just
business partners this desaad now for
nearly a decade I'm not I'm not really
sure why I chose you for this but
whatever that's why I always say like oh
you know like I left for boarding school
when Hank was 11 it's to make up for the
fact that I I have no memories of him
from childhood because we were not in
fact brothers orange did I say it right
that time you said it my way that car is
orange nope it's so hard to say in one
syllable that car is orange my my
Nickelodeon Kids Choice Award that I'm
staring at right now is orange
it seems very weird to say okay Kids
Choice Award I do I have a Kids Choice
Award I didn't mean to brag but I do
have one I don't even remember what it's
for actually I should I'm gonna guess
the Fault in Our Stars we got another
question I don't I think it's I think
it's for a book of some kind but yeah go
what's that I have to remind you John
that The Fault in Our Stars is indeed a
book of some kind
oh right I forgot that there was a book
before the movie this one's from Zach
who asks dear Hank and John I was
listening to the episode where you guys
discussed what time of day it's
appropriate start saying have a good
night rather than have a good day
and it made me think of a problem that I
have constantly here how do I decide
which phrase I should use to end a
letter or email before Sun in my name
who deserves a love Zach rather than a
from Zach or sincerely Zach or best
wishes Zach which Zach didn't actually
write it it'd be great if you guys could
lay out some ground rules for what
closing phrase should be used in
different relationships thanks for the
help love from sincerely Zach I actually
think that Hank and I are both pretty
bad at this so we're not great we're not
going to be great arbiters of this
discussion if I end any email with
anything it is just the letter H yeah
Amy Krauss Rosenthal has a bit in her
new book about how annoying it is when
people sign off with just their initials
from emails as if like they don't have
the energy to type the extra three
characters that is their name but I
usually sign off I usually sign off best
wishes but I think Zach this is a great
opportunity for you to develop you know
like a personal signature like a
catchphrase
that's you know sort of Zack specific
now this is of course a very risky game
because most personal catchphrases are
super cringy you don't I mean Hank you
think that wait like [ __ ] so should
everybody be developing a personal
catchphrase of their own or are we
creating one that everyone should be
using I I didn't really I haven't really
thought this bit through so I'm
open-minded I'm just going through my
email right now and seeing how I how I
sign off my emails and it is I often do
type out Hank but mostly my emails end
with some some modification of does that
make sense
it tends to be how I end all of my
emails I like write a bunch of stuff and
then I'm like am I crazy what do you
think I don't know am i your boss I'm
not really just do your job oh that is
kind of how you end most of your emails
it's funny actually Hank just just a
couple hours ago you sent me an email
but because of some kind of like email
handle mix-up it came from Julie's are
like Chief of Operations it came from
her email address but it was so
obviously written by Hank that I wrote
her back and I was like I think that
Hank wrote this email and she was like
oh yeah I got to figure out what just
happened so you don't have a I do have
an email style but you don't have a
sign-off like Shazam right right right
I'm not saying it should be Shazam I'm
just saying that is an email sign-off
the other one that so I have a friend
who always writes yours
why are s comma returned returned and
then their name which I've always kind
of liked like it's it's sort of
old-fashioned and weird but very
specific and then I have another friend
who I shall not name but is an extremely
famous and successful author who always
signs off their emails until anon oh wow
every time every time until anon and I
don't really know what that means what
if it was like it was like a cutesy fun
thing like pumpkins and penguins Hank oh
man pumpkins and penguins I mean it's
kind of cutesy but like when you're
emailing the CEO of YouTube do you
really want to end it with pumpkins and
penguins yes hey Susan Wojcicki Hank
green here hope all's well just a couple
quick notes on the YouTube D
monetization crisis pumpkins and
penguins Hank I like it I'm going with
it I think it's a terrible idea and it
could literally kill our business I
which which leads me to forgot about our
sponsor this week which is of course the
pump pumpkins and penguins Association
of America yeah pumpkins and penguins
they don't have a ton to do with each
other but we formed this organization
for efficiency sake to advocate upon
both both of their behalf I mean what
are like what are the shared issues of
pumpkins and penguins I guess they're
both concerned about climate change like
all species sure uh-huh
yeah they don't know mmm
not very much it's like a raven and a
writing-desk kind of situation okay I've
got something that pumpkins and penguins
have in common they both waddle like
pumpkins don't actually waddle but you
can tell that they would if they had
feet if you give them a little shove
they'll they'll wobble at least which is
like waterway right so like the Penguins
and pumpkins Association of America is
standing up for you know organisms
rights to waddle mm-hmm and they both
are composed of flesh they have flesh
inside of them so they're yeah I'm sure
penguins Association of America is Pro
flesh and the preservation reflex yeah
and like not having your flesh scooped
out from the inside so that you become a
hollow corpse with a light inside of it
like that's another big issue for both
penguins and you know honestly I have to
say though that that's probably the only
thing keeping the pumpkins industry
alive so they're probably really Pro
scooping out flesh and having a light
placed inside where there used to be
life it's pretty vital to the
continuation of the pumpkin as a species
since it's such a terrible food yeah did
you know John that like the pumpkin mix
at the store that you get to like make
pumpkin pies with it is
it isn't even made had a pumpkin because
pumpkin is of course not pumpkins are
disgusting which by the way is another
thing that pumpkins and penguins have in
common their flesh is basically inedible
oh yeah yeah
penguin flesh is not good did you know
John that penguin flesh is so rich in
fat that you can throw it like you can
literally have a fire composed of only
penguin flesh mmm that is that is
disturbing let's move on to what else
brought us this podcast today right we
were in the middle of that today's
podcast has also brought to you by M&Ms
peanut M&Ms peanut just like the Honda
Civic just like it also advocated before
by the Honda Civic and M&Ms peanut
Association of America and also this
podcast is brought to you by John's
teeth real bad because of bad decisions
and mistakes that were made and of
course today's podcast is brought to you
by the color or ran jock the color or
Anja no wrong way to say it alright John
do you want to do another question yeah
let's do a quick one this one is from
Jazlyn who asks dear Hank and John in
the morning in my office people walk
past my desk quickly and ask how are you
and then keep walking so that when I say
the customary good they are gone already
right makes me feel bad yeah I've tried
beating them to it but when I say how
are you they say how are you and keep
walking is this normal what is the
correct response to in office how are
yous yeah I mean this is normal but it
is also a huge problem yeah I actually
have a strategy for this that I think is
pretty great I don't I don't usually
like to toot my own horn but I feel like
the way that I deal with this is pretty
good which is that I go with the
pre-emptive great like people like like
before they even finish the sentence
they're like how are you great
ya know before they even say the hell
right so like the whole problem is that
this person is walking past you they're
saying how are you they don't actually
care how you are but you want to tell
them how you are so I just go with the
pre-emptive great I make eye contact
while they're walking at me and then
they start to open their mouths and you
can see the huh in how being made with
their mouths and you great
I like this is a sound the sound of
military strategy John it is it has
taken it to another level can I can I
ask a question kind of a bad day broke
my rib yeah no you should like III
honest like I think this is terrible
and there are so many things you could
say that aren't that that like express
like a connection without like starting
a conversation that you have no intent
of finishing why not just say good
morning hello mm-hmm like why not just
like we talked in a previous podcast why
people don't just say good morning it's
because it's extremely stressful you've
got to know exactly what time it is to
say good morning otherwise you risk the
1202 retort like you could just like be
walking past Jocelyn and be like jaslyne
like you just say the name like like
yeah nice you know who I am that's Bruce
also nice to see you right but I like
that that's my favorite interaction in
an office place is just like jaslyne
Bruce I love that I think that's such a
good that's a solid conversation it's
two people who have acknowledged each
other who have named each other it's
great Jazlyn Bruce is the ideal office
place banter but if somebody's gonna say
how are you regularly to you and not
listen to the answer you've got to like
up the stakes and let them know that
this isn't okay and that's why you use
the pre-emptive answer and I don't wait
wait what about this what what about if
we meld these two strategies and when
when someone says to Jesslyn how are you
she says Bruce every time Bruce walks by
and says hey hey Jasmine how are you she
just says Bruce it doesn't even have to
be Bruce just anybody no I think it's
better if you say the person's name back
to them like because they are basically
having completely different conversation
than the one that you're involved in
they're just orienting it toward you so
why don't you just have a completely
different conversation from the one that
having and oriented toward them ya know
I like that I like that but yeah I just
if you're I mean I have I don't like
this is weird like when I walk past
people's offices and we make eye contact
and I'm like wave awkwardly as but I
don't want to like stop on my way to the
bathroom I just like wave and like let
my hand to sort of trail behind me so
they can continue seeing it as I wave
and then oh I hit my guitar and then it
was waving and then and then like move
on and continue moving but I'm not want
to like stop and be like
Jazlyn Bruce mmm because I like do your
work I don't want to interrupt you doing
your work I always as I as I know as I
walk down the hallway to my office I
just shout everyone's name I'm just like
zulay assured and Mark Stan Sarah it's
not not the right way to be a boss I
thought like when you're a boss you just
say everyone's name authoritative Lee
and then they think that you're managing
rosianna yeah oh man that would be if I
looked into this sideshow studio that
would be real weird
I'd be like Lou Kaitlyn Stefan Haruka
Sarah Sarah maggot all right I think
that we have run this question into the
ground Hank and it's time to move on to
the news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon
standing in the middle of room shouting
people's names and then you walk out can
I go first right can I go first
can I go first can I go first is it good
news guess who won a game Oh was it not
the team that was playing against AFC
Wimbledon that's right it was not the
team playing against AFC Wimbledon and
see Wimbledon emerged victorious in
their first win of the League One season
against Chesterfield suck at
Chesterfield
how was Chesterfield placed in the table
their 13th so uh which by the way is one
spot ahead of the franchise currently
playing in Milton Keynes so yeah and
that victory Hank means that in six
games AFC Wimbledon have acquired five
points
which doesn't sound great until you
realize that it means they are no longer
in the bottom four which means that if
the season ended today
they would narrowly escaped relegation
Wow I that I mean if you guys can stay
in the league one it's less fun up here
but I assume there's another advantages
oh yeah no more money in fact AFC
Wimbledon's gonna be on TV next month
tank proper British TV and is that like
are you gonna be able to spend money on
players then is that the goal
oh I mean listen the the game is about
community so the goal has already been
achieved because there's a great
community around the club but yeah I
mean obviously you want to win games and
move up in the leagues and I you know my
dream is someday to see AFC Wimbledon in
the Premier League again but that's
that's a that's a long way from now need
a new stadium among other things but
right now I think the goal for this
season is to stay in the third tier by
the way somebody asked why do you keep
calling it League one if it's the third
tier which is a fascinating story so
there's the Premier League which is
where like Chelsea and Manchester United
play that is the top league in England
the second league in England is
helpfully known as the championship
which you know sounds like it's the best
league but it's the second best and then
the third league is known as League One
on account of it being one league above
the fourth league which is League Two
which itself is above the fifth League
which is called the conference national
it's a completely unhelpful tier system
but yeah the yeah the third tier is
League one so hopefully next year we'll
be in the championship although with a
very long way to go for that to happen
oh my what's the news from Mars well you
know the coolest thing on the surface of
Mars is the Mars Curiosity rover right
John I know that the that there is
currently a minivan on Mars yes it's
been driving around on the sort of like
planes maybe possibly former lakebed at
the base of a mountain on Mars and it is
headed up right now it's sort of reached
the the edge of that mountain and the
plan is to have it go up the side of the
mountain a little bit but
there may need to change the places that
the Mars Curiosity rover goes in order
to avoid places where there is like
suddenly we are realizing liquid water
on Mars so in the last year we and you
know basically realize that there are
these weird formations that that that
are they recur and they are darkening of
the Martian surface and that they are
liquid water sort of hydrates you know a
weird chemical thing happening with
salts and water and we really do not
there's a there's a international treaty
that says you cannot take a earth bound
thing and have it touch liquid water on
Mars
so stay as far away from that as you can
in the future you don't want to like
find life living in the water on Mars
and be like Oh life on Mars but then be
like oh but did we put it there
accidentally when we drove the Curiosity
rover up to that liquid stuff right now
curiosity could not actually drive up to
and test even if it wanted to like do
science on this I think that would be
amazing but it can't because all of the
areas where this happens are very very
steep and the steepness sort of is
required for them to to happen and all
in this the level of slope that would
require be required for these RSL's
these water streaks to happen curiosity
could not exist on that level of thing
it would flip over so we aren't gonna
have that happen even if we wanted it to
happen but it the current path is
through an area where there are actually
tons of these which is interesting
because like you know two years ago we
didn't know they existed at all and now
we're like Oh Mars is covered in them so
it actually has to kind of be careful
and we may need to redraw the path that
we thought curiosity was going to go on
to make sure that it doesn't get too
close to any of this of this you know
liquid water on Mars which is an amazing
weird thing to have to deal with and a
very exciting thing to have to deal with
but it's also just exciting that that
curiosity is now heading into a very
different part of the geology of the
area that it was that it landed in and
it's gonna keep finding all kinds of new
stuff and it has moved so far since it
arrived on the planet and it has a lot a
lot more to go so how many miles has it
moved so far it's traveled more than 10
kilometers I don't know exactly how long
it is gone but that's like that's like
six miles right yeah no I can run that
in an hour
but I I you know I understand I'm not on
Mars I understand it's harder it's
harder and it's uh yeah and they've been
doing science as they've gone they've
paused it's not it's not like it's been
running at a breakneck pace across the
Martian surface for you know three years
now it mostly is it's mostly sits around
and doing doing stuff taking pictures
drilling holes shooting things with Mars
lasers well I mean I just I just hope it
keeps doing its work alone on that
planet until roundabout 2028 all right
John what do we learn today well we
learned that Hank and John say orange
differently or possibly orange or orange
indicating that we may not be brothers
and are just strangers who make videos
to get possible it's possible we learned
that John has bad teeth and a bad bad
systems for dealing with stress at the
dentist's office bunch of bunch of flaws
and of course we learned that Zac should
sign off all of his emails even those to
the CEO of YouTube pumpkins and penguins
and of course finally we learned that if
you want to secretly learn to play
fiddle for three years before surprising
all of your family it is going to have
to be a fairly elaborate prank that we
really want to see executed oh man he is
my hero
I just I just I want this to happen so
bad I was gonna say I've never wanted
anything this bad but that's just not
true I've wanted I've wanted many many
many things worse but I do want it I do
want it so bad
for PA
I do want to say Pia if this doesn't end
up happening we will not be disappointed
at you that's fine there's many things
that you want to get done in your life
and this is only one I just know but you
know the reason I think P is gonna have
almost by definition an extraordinary
life Hank is because of the first
sentence the confidence with which she
wrote that first sentence how do I tell
my family that I have secretly learned
to play the fiddle at this point in her
mind the three years she's gonna have to
spend learning to play the fiddle she's
already done that basically okay well
thank you for listening to today's
podcast if you want to support the
podcast directly and get access to
monthly live shows with Hank and me you
can do so at patreon.com slash dear Hank
and John we really appreciate all the
support this podcast is edited by
nicholas jenkins our intern it is her
last week is Claudia Morales thank you
so much Claudia for all your great work
on dear Hank and John
rosianna halse rojas helps us out with
the questions our theme music is by
gunnarolla and I just want to say thank
you to all the people who have written
lyrics to Hank and John have got it
going on I've seen I think more of them
so far and I will include a couple of
the best YouTube videos on the patreon
that you can go check out um because
there are some wonderful versions of
Hank and John have got it going on
involving us and our purple tanks also I
should say that you should you can email
us at Hank and John at gmail.com or
follow us on Twitter Hank is Hank green
I'm John Green you can also follow Hank
on snapchat where he is Hank gr E and of
course if you're gonna follow anyone on
Twitter it should be Leon Moss at Leon
must number for Earth Leon must for
Earth no one is working harder to keep
humans on Earth only species until at
least 20 28 all right I think that this
debate does it John
and as they say in our hometown don't
forget to be awesome
you